free parking
free palestine muhammad is an artist
and an activist his canvas is madrid
whether it's legal or not is another
matter
it's my first night with him here in
spain and i'm already thinking
what the hell have i got myself into
ohio
muhammad says people on the street often
support his work
even older people help him by watching
out for the police
or tonight they're not so supportive
you know
muhammad is a syrian palestinian refugee
he's seen bigger troubles than some
little tiff over a rubbish bin
what if the police would come now like
what would be the consequence
like maybe you would give you a bill for
three thousand this is the left
maybe nine thousand so you cannot make
it anymore
if you cannot pay maybe man yeah maybe
you could spend two years in jail for
doing something like that
so you're not afraid of that kind of
yeah
like but it's not scares me as
as damn is that the whole situation is
going on i mean like a lot of situations
really bad and much worse so
you have to be like in action and even
like take responsibility
for telling us okay you know the police
already caught him once
but that's obviously not holding him
back
graffiti is just one of the ways
muhammad raises awareness
as i'm about to find out
muhammad worries about protecting his
identity
years ago he got into trouble with the
police in syria for speaking out about
the way he was treated there as a child
of palestinian refugees
he draws comics about people like
himself
people without a country
based on the comics he and his friends
are also developing an online video game
in it players become zatun the little
palestinian refugee
they have to face challenges like what
to do if your family's home gets bombed
you'll be like imported to the same
situation that palestinian refugees has
been to
to live so you're going to be like also
unfriended to the decision they have to
make
like for example this case like zeitung
had to leave syria but he didn't know
where to go so you have to help say to
him decide this stuff
and this is the animal camp this was the
first image like we saw that people got
excited and this is when we take the
decision to create the platform
i know it touched me really like yeah
watching your family is also leaving
again
the game is based on real videos shot by
muhammad's friends who still live in
yarmouk
the palestinian refugee camp outside
damascus where he was born
and raised since the war broke out in
syria
yarmouk has been under siege
all of you guys escaped except for
your best friend who had to stay in the
camp yeah
after like they seized their camp it was
impossible for
anyone to leave the camp and after he
just got really hopeless
one day he got the chance to leave the
camp they caught him outside on the
checkpoint
and yeah after a month like of torture
his gut died
muhammad probably would have died too or
ended up in prison
if he hadn't got out in time now he's
trying to do what he can
in exile to make people care
muhammad may be thousands of kilometers
out of danger
but there's no escaping the war in syria
when he hears the news about bombings
near his old home he's glad he got out
but he also feels guilty for the people
who didn't
wherever we go in madrid muhammad's
refugees are there in silent protest
he won a bob's award for the online
version of their stories of displacement
do you feel at home here in madrid kind
of
or on in a transit yeah
like it's basically both of them it's
been like five years now i can feel
yeah i can feel like i have my own space
i
feel like a kind of no it's not
not say home because i feel like it's
like
always you have to move somewhere that's
like being a refugee
you have the oldest feeling we're gonna
we one day we're gonna want to go back
on palestine
so like each place for you is like some
kind of transition
you have to invent a new one it's like
do you call your friends your family so
you change like concepts i know what is
home you know
the
muhammad organizes painting workshops
for kids like these roma children
so they can express their own
experiences of refugee life
the kids are also inspiration for new
cartoon and video game characters
takes me to a former tobacco plant to
paint more characters from his video
game
so what about like making a new car
right now it's layla the syrian refugee
how many of of you is in these
characters
um basically i try to
to represent stuff i feel in this
character layla for example
is is my side of being syrian zeitung is
my side of being palestinian
so i can express my syrian side from
laila and my palestinians
from zaitun the first time muhammad
graffiti zaytun was on the walls of the
palestinian authority's office in berlin
he'd gone there for help with his asylum
application
but they turned him away because he was
born in syria
he came back with spray cans expressing
yourself
from earth is for me it's helped me a
lot to
i know to clean myself from like inside
this situation
of of something that i do not agree
about outside
i have really a lot of anger with me
because because like seeing
exposed to this situation and feeling
like well the whole world ignorance like
you feel you're gonna explore inside you
feel like you wanna tell something
that the world don't want to listen so
so you keep like painting it
muhammad is one of millions who've seen
the world around them blow up
even if no one is listening to him now
he won't stop
telling their story